And I'm so sorry.
Okay,
so momentarily we're going to return to
the basic story
and I want to talk to you today about
how your brain organizes your
perceptions and then I want to talk to
you about how that's represented in
hematology.
First thing I'd like to point out is
that we talked about the difference
between Darwinian,
the Newtonian viewpoints a while back,
and one of the,
okay,
one claim that you might make if you
were a Darwinian is that whatever your
brain is adapted to his reality.
No,
I mean that seems to me to be the
central claim of Darwinian evolution is
that you can't define reality any more
accurately than that which selects.
Now I want to tell you about how I think
the brain is organized and then I want
to show you,
I hope that the way fundamental
narratives work can be mapped onto that
brain structure.
And
to me that implies that there's
something right about the fundamental
narratives because otherwise why would
they map onto the brain structures that
have evolved to adapt as to the
environment?
Now you don't.
People think about reality.
I know subjective terms and they think
about it as decomposable into tiny sub
units.
But I think that that's a limited
viewpoint,
a powerful but limited viewpoint.
I think it's much more realistic to
assume that whatever reality is is more
like a continual interplay,
a very,
very complex patterns.
And
I suppose you could make the case that
those patterns are ultimately made out
of particles,
but that's even,
that's not exactly true because the
particles have to be arrayed in space.
So that's part of the atomic theory is
that there's not just particles,
subatomic particles and atomic
particles,
but if they're arrayed in space and if
there are rate in space,
that means the manner in which they're
are rate can be informative.
And if you reduce the phenomena to the
particle without taking into account the
patterning of the array of particles,
then there's levels and levels and
levels of information that you lose and
those information that those levels of
information are,
they may not be relevant for our
physical understanding of the,
of the makeup of atomic and subatomic
particles.
But they're definitely relevant to
whether or not we can walk across the
street.
And so I would say
if you're related to reality properly,
the kind of information that you're
processing is precisely the kind of
information that allows you to cross the
street properly and to do all the other
things during your day and your weeks
and your months that you have to in
order to stay alive and,
and,
and fundamentally in some sense to
propagate.
So,
all right,
so we'll start with the
neuropsychological argument.
Now we've already established the idea
that these little frames of reference or
maps or stories or whatever you call
them,
I'll call them stories,
I think from here on in our little goal
directed units.
And there are units of conception and
emotion and perception and behavior,
their little subpersonalities and
there's some personality has an initial
starting point and a destination point.
And then it can implement behaviors to
transform the starting point into the
destination point.
And then you might say,
well,
what forms these little
subpersonalities?
And the answer to that is very complex,
but one answer is fundamental motivate
motivations.
And so I arranged the fundamental
motivations on this particular
diagram pointed out that you can roughly
consider motivations as those that
maintain you and those that propagate
you.
Now it's just a heuristic,
it's just a way of thinking about it.
Um,
under self maintenance there's thermal
regulation,
thirst,
hunger and elimination.
There's all sorts of other things as
well,
but those will do for the time being.
And then under self propagation there's
affiliate of desire and sexual desire.
Now the thing that's quite interesting
about all this is that you know,
there are,
there are brain structures that underlie
these fundament,
the manifestation of these fundamental
subpersonalities.
Now people tend to think about them
either as motivations or emotions.
And I think that's a use and other
useful heuristic.
And that you could say roughly speaking,
that a motivation pops up,
an entire frame of reference and an
emotion tends to orient you within that
frame of reference.
But that's only a conceptual
simplification because what you see when
you look at the actual brain structures
is that like there isn't an emotion
center.
There are a bunch of micro units in the
brain.
And each of,
and there are separable micro units for
different emotions and different
motivations and they don't necessarily
have that much in common in terms of
their locale except that they tend to be
relatively deep in the brain.
So some are hypothalamic and summer in
the Amygdala in summer in the
periaqueductal gray,
which seems to be responsible for pain
responses and so we can classify things
as motivations and emotions,
but that doesn't map one to one on the
underlying brain structures.
Now I think what we'll do with regards
to talking about the brain is we'll
start from the bottom up and it's
appropriate to start from the bottom up
because you are more dependent on your
ancient brain structures.
Then you are on your modern brain
structures in that if you damage your
modern brain structures,
and I mean relatively modern,
let's say the ones that have really
evolved in great detail over the last 2
million years,
the cortical cap,
particular the prefrontal Cortex,
a lot of the visual Cortex,
if you damage that,
you can pretty much go on.
Now you know you're going to have one
impairment or another impairment,
but you can still stay alive.
However,
there are structures that are lower down
that if you damage,
that's the end of you.
So for example,
the ascending reticular activating
system,
which is the thing that wakes you up
when you're asleep at night,
when you,
when a noise occurs that shouldn't
occur,
it's,
it seems to be the activating center for
consciousness,
whatever that means.
It's way deep down in the brain.
It's way down at the top of the spinal
cord,
roughly speaking.
And if you twist your head in a car
accident a little bit too roughly,
and you shear off they ascending fibers,
then you're in a coma permanently and
nothing can wake you up.
And that's pretty interesting.
You know,
that consciousness,
which we think of again,
you know,
our tendency is to think about that as a
function of the higher cortical systems
is dependent completely on something
that's unbelievably ancient.
So,
you know,
and it begs the question,
well at exactly what level of neuronal
complexity do you have to be before you
have some consciousness.
And the answer to that is we don't know
because of the relationship between
consciousness and neuronal structure is
insanely complex.
So for example,
you have very neurone neuron heavy
structures in your brain.
The cerebellum,
which has about as many,
it has a very rough outer coding like
the cortex and it has about as many
neurons as the cortical she does.
And yet you can take it out of people.
They don't seem to show any impairment
of consciousness,
but they,
they,
you know,
they get a tax sick and they can't
control their behavior that well.
They have a hard time guiding it and,
but that seems to be more or less it now
it isn't because there is other things
the cerebellum does,
but my point is you can have massive
massively neuron heavy structures that
seem to be related in,
in very minimal ways to our experience
of consciousness.
You know,
in your autonomic nervous system is sort
of like that too.
There's a lot of neurons in your
autonomic nervous system.
But I think it's a mistake to say that
we're precisely conscious of our
autonomic nervous system,
although now and then we're conscious of
its outputs,
you know,
it governs our,
the operation of our organs and all the
things that are so complex that we
aren't allowed to mess with them as
conscious beings,
but it's not conscious.
And then while somehow some neurons are
conscious and we,
I tell you,
we don't know anything about
consciousness.
We really don't.
We don't have a clue.
And I think it's probably because we're
formulating the question wrong.
You know,
those people are people who are
materialists reductionists and they
believe that consciousness is an
emergent property of the underlying
neuronal neuronal function.
But the problem with that philosophy is
that it's predicated on the assumption
that they understand what the matter is
that's making up that neuronal
substrate.
And I can tell you that by the time we
were able to reduce consciousness to its
underlying material structure,
we'll think of whatever matter is in a
way that's completely different than the
way we think of it now.
You know,
so there might be an eventual reduction,
but at the same time there's going to be
a transformation of the theories.
You know,
it's clear that we don't understand
material that well,
particularly because when you go down
into the underlying,
you know,
the tiny underlying substructures at the
subatomic level,
it behaves in a very,
very peculiar manner.
So,
so anyways,
you know,
all bets are off with regards to
consciousness,
but it also does seem to be something
that's likely very ancient,
you know,
and uh,
there are people who've attributed
consciousness to insects.
Insects by the way,
seem to go out of their way to take
hallucinogenic drugs,
which is quite interesting.
So the,
the Flyer Garrett for example,
is a mushroom that,
it's the famous red and white mushroom
that you always see in fairy tales and
in Super Mario brothers and like it pops
up everywhere and flies will come and
take a bite of it.
And then they fall unconscious beside
the mushroom and they stay there for
like 10 or 15 minutes and then they get
up.
But they'll go eat it again.
And reindeer really like them too.
And they get blitzed out of their mind
on m,
Anita miscarriers.
And so it,
and,
and there's,
there's evidence for the desire to
transform states of consciousness way,
way down in the animal kingdom,
way farther than you'd think.
So you know,
God only knows and then you think,
well,
a big brain is necessary,
but you consider something like,
uh,
Irene Pepperberg,
um,
African gray parrot,
which died a couple of years ago,
a famous animal which could speak better
than a three year old kid,
four year old kid,
and had a good,
good vocabulary.
More than 500 words.
And it could put together meaningful
phrases.
It could speak better than a chimpanzee.
They use sign language of course.
But like this was one smart bird.
And if they think about a bird,
I mean,
it has no brain a bird.
It's got a brain like this big.
And now I know a bird isn't very big and
that actually makes a difference.
But the fact that that much intelligence
can be packed into that small an area
means as far as I'm concerned,
that we don't really understand very
much about how the brain works.
But we do understand some things and
most of the things we understand have
actually been discovered by animal
experimentalists,
which,
uh,
which is a useful thing to know because
of course there's lots of people who
don't think that animal experimentation
is a good idea.
Or that we could substitute computer
models,
which is of course a Spec,
spectacularly idiotic theory.
Because obviously if we had accurate
computer models,
we wouldn't need to do the animal
experimentation,
you know,
so we're not going to build a computer
model that's better than our current
understanding,
at least not,
not yet.
We May,
we may in the future.
So anyways,
you can think of the basic elements,
the basic structures that are producing
these little subpersonalities,
um,
as,
as the output of fundamental biological
systems are their motivations or
emotions and the structure that appears
to be most responsible for this sort of
thing.
At least initially is the hypothalamus.
And I should show you a little bit about
the hypothalamus,
just so you kind of have a sense of what
it is.
Um,
it's not very big and you see in this
diagram that it sits right on top of
this,
of the spinal cord and the base part of
the brain.
So that's just that little bitty area
there,
which,
you know,
it looks from the diagram to be maybe
one,
1% of the entire brain mass or something
like that.
And I think I mentioned to you before
that if you take a cat and you take all
of its brain off except the
hypothalamus,
roughly speaking,
as long as it's a female cat in a
restricted environment,
it can pretty much live a cat life
except that it's hyper exploratory,
which I do think is quite remarkable.
You know,
cause you'd think it would just lay
there passively,
right with,
since it doesn't have a brain,
but,
um,
the hypothalamus,
and I'll show you some more pictures
here about types.
They all must.
So this is a rat hypothalamus and this
is a diagram from Larry Swanson who's a
real genius and well worth reading,
although very complicated.
Um,
he's a developmental neuro anatomist if
I remember correctly.
And he's interested in how the brain and
folds across the course of feet of fetal
development and all sorts of different
animals.
You know,
assuming that by doing that in part you
can track the evolution,
but you can also understand the
relationship between one brain part in
another.
Now what you see here,
you see all those little subunits of the
Hypothalamus,
they're,
they're um,
indicated in orange,
green and black.
And so the first thing that you can see
is that the hypothalamus is not one
thing.
It's a bunch of,
what do you call those?
Um,
Ganglia I think is the correct name for
the hypothalamic sub organs.
And so it's called a hypothalamus sort
of for convenience sake.
You know,
I mean,
you can identify it anatomically and it
might be a good shorthand for,
you know,
a rough description of the,
of the macro structure of the brain.
But of course the problem with the brain
is,
is that,
you know,
it's pattern one at this level and it's
pattern to at this level it's pattern
three at this level.
And you know,
you can go a long ways down before you
run out of complexity and a cell is an
unbelievably complicated thing and you
have,
God only knows how many of those things
in your brain I think,
I don't remember exactly what the latest
estimates are,
but it's in the hundreds of billions in
each of those cells is like,
it's complex as a,
as a factory in some,
like a really complex factory and it's
full.
They're full of these little molecular
machines that are doing things that are
so complicated and amazing.
You just can't believe it when you,
I've seen,
you know,
computer animations of some of these
structures and operation there.
The complexity of what they do,
you know,
to,
to take the DNA molecule apart and men
too.
And then to rebuild it little bit by
little bit and to do error correction at
the same time.
It's like I,
it just boggles the mind.
You can't,
you cannot,
I cannot see how you can possibly
account for that.
Using a straight,
sort of Newtonian deterministic model
of,
of like,
of clockwork behavior.
The stuff is so sophisticated,
you know,
it looks more like advanced robotics
than it does like the,
you know,
the interaction of tiny little
molecules.
There are molecules that work with the
DNA that can walk and as they walk,
they carry other molecules.
And not only can they think things walk,
they can walk over obstacles.
It's like,
and they're like,
they're like made out of 10 molecules.
It's like,
what's going on?
You know,
it just,
it's just beyond belief.
Okay.
So all of these little nucleus nuclei
are,
I think that's what they're called,
actually,
nuclei in the hypothalamus.
They're all doing slightly different
things.
So there's subserving while they're
radically different things,
although they have a commonality of
function.
And so roughly what you could say is
that one half of the hypothalamus is
devoted to popping up these little
subpersonalities that are devoted to
the,
uh,
um,
satiation,
the satisfaction of fundamental
biological requirements.
And so,
you know,
it's not obvious what a fundamental
biological requirement is because again,
that's a heuristic.
It's not a club.
It's not a category,
but we can agree it's a fuzzy category,
but we can agree on some of its
contents.
And so of course thirst and hunger and
the need to breathe would be in there.
And then we might also add pain and
sexual desire and um,
the need for play,
although that's a separate circuit and
it's not mediated by hypothalamic
structures.
There's a different circuit for play,
play,
slash,
affiliation.
So,
but roughly speaking,
the,
the what an animal basically chases and
requires on a day to day and week to
week basis is mediated in large part by
the hypothalamus.
And the hypothalamus is also a crucial
nexus in the brain for identifying
what's going on in the body and then
telling the brain what to do about it.
So for example,
the hypothalamus is the thing that makes
you hungry and the thing that makes you
thirsty.
And it does that because it monitors
levels of,
of,
of substances such as sugar in your
bloodstream.
And,
and also,
um,
you know,
the degree to which you're hydrated and
you can,
um,
sustain tiny little bits of damage to
the hypothalamus with unbelievably
extreme consequences.
So for example,
if you get unlucky,
you can develop hyperphosphatemia or I
don't remember the technical for it,
but uncontrollable thirst.
And so if that part of your hypothalamus
is damaged,
people just can't keep you away from
water supplies.
He'll just drink and drink and drink and
drink and drink and drink and drink
until you drown and you can't control
it.
So the hypothalamus is no joke in
hyperphagic has the same thing except in
relationship to food.
So,
and on,
there have been reports of people who've
developed all,
I knew a guy in Montreal who,
who used to work at Harvard,
his name was Frank Irvin,
and he did some of the earliest studies
at,
in the world on the physiology of
violent crime.
And frank had identified,
um,
the role of epilepsy as a progenitor to
violent crimes.
And so,
you know,
the defensive rage circuit as part of
the hypothalamus.
And if you,
if you're unlucky,
you can have a particular form of
epilepsy that will activate the
defensive rage system.
I knew someone who had,
who had a seizure condition like that,
and then they get uncontrollably
aggressive.
Now this guy is quite an interesting
story.
So it first happened to him when he was
about 18 and he was out drinking in a
bar and alcohol lowers your seizure
threshold.
So it was out drinking in a bar and all
of a sudden he got up and tore his shirt
off and then his friends were coming.
Like he was in an aggressive stance and
backed into the corner and his friends
were coming close to him and he told
them,
go away or I'll hit you.
Now.
He was a very well socialized person.
So I think what happened is that he went
into this defensive rage state,
but because he was so well socialized,
he could tell people to stay that way,
stay away from him.
But he couldn't stop himself from
hitting them and attacking them if they
got close enough.
So anyways,
I believe at that point he slapped a
police officer who came to rescue them
and they took him to the hospital.
And on the way there he hit his fingers
against the hood of the car and put
dents in it.
And then when he got up to the hospital,
now I don't remember the particulars of
this,
but he picked up a kidney bowl,
which is like an enamel covered steel
ball and twisted it in an in a figure
eight.
It's like,
yeah,
try that.
It's not so easy.
So in the next time it happened,
he was in another bar.
And so what Ha,
what the hypothesis was then was that
someone had spiked his alcohol with some
sort of drug gay,
but he went.
But that was never demonstrated.
But he got off of all that because he
had no record.
He was a perfectly peaceful person.
And then the next time it happened,
he was in another bar and he did the
same thing.
He backed into corner,
ripped off his shirt.
And then he told me that when he was
looking,
he looked down the hallway and all he
could see was fire.
And then a police woman came to to get
him because of the bar phone,
the police and he hit her.
And then after that he had eeg testing,
which showed that he was susceptible to
seizures.
And so he swore off alcohol.
I've never had another drink and he's
like 35 now.
I never had another drink in his life.
And it never happened again.
But it's just a good example of of,
there was a kid at the University of
Texas at Austin about 30 years ago who
had seemed to have a perfectly
reasonable,
you know,
family life and so forth,
reasonable upbringing.
And he started to become increasingly
violent in his fantasies and he climbed
up onto a tower cause there was a high
tower at the University of Texas at
Austin and he took a high powered rifle
and I think he shot 16 people before
they finally got him.
And you know,
when they,
when they did an autopsy at a fast
growing tumor that was pressing on the
hypothalamus.
So the hypothalamus is no joke.
You know?
And for those of you whose introduction
to neuropsychology has made you assumed
that the Cortex is in control,
let me tell you,
the cortex is only con in control when
you,
when all of your other basic
requirements are satiated.
And since you're a modern person and you
live in luxury that's unparalleled in
the history of the world,
all of your fundamental biological sub
personalities are always satiated.
And so that's what you think you're
like,
but you're only like that because you've
beat,
you never been anywhere where you
weren't like that.
So,
so anyways,
now here's one of the things that's cool
about the hypothalamus.
So the first thing is,
is you have these different subsystems
say these different nuclear that are
responsible for these different
subpersonalities oriented towards
sexuality,
oriented towards hunger,
oriented towards Thurs,
oriented towards temperature regulation,
et Cetera.
You know,
and I think of them as sub personalities
because they have a viewpoint.
They want something that they want to go
somewhere,
they want to accomplish it efficiently,
and they have emotions that go along
with it.
So that,
you know,
if you're going for some water and you
drop a glass or somebody gets in your
way,
or the tap is working,
you're going to feel frustration and
anxiety and irritation.
So they come fully equipped with
emotions.
They have their own motor outputs,
which they basically prime.
And those would be the motor outputs
that are,
uh,
aggregations of habits that you have
been able to learn that have the eight
of you previously in your water
searching behavior.
So for us,
that would be,
you know,
getting a glass out of the cupboard.
That's a gripping issue.
And then a transport issue.
And then you have to turn on the tap.
And so,
and Luria who a famous Russian
neuropsychologist called those things
kinetic melodies.
And so if you think about it from a p a
jetty and perspective and alluring in
perspective,
at the same time,
you can think that piaget talked about
how children put together basic,
you know,
motor they're not reflex is exactly
their complex sequences of what started
as reflexes.
And then those can be linked together in
a,
in a sort of,
in this sort of dance that you're always
doing with your body and each of those
little dances,
you know,
we think water seeking,
you're going to have a set of water
relevant dances that you can do that you
know your experiences taught you to
become expert at.
And when you get thirsty then knows or
liked the dis-inhibited.
That's my guess.
They're
disinhibited and prepared for execution,
you know,
and then the specifics of the
circumstance that you're in determine
which ones are deceiving is inhibited
enough to actually run.
It's like you're full of little machines
and they're all on there ready to go,
but they're all shut.
They're all like held in status in some
sense by cortical inhibition.
It's like,
I like to think of the brain,
sort of like a nuclear reactor,
you know,
the core is really active,
it's on,
but then you have all these rods going
into the core to keep it from,
from uh,
going critical.
And the CORTEX is sort of like that in
relationship to the lower parts of the
brain.
Those parts of the brain,
man,
they're,
they're alive.
They're like,
they're like the titans of mythology.
You know,
they're sitting down there,
these fundamental forces and they're
ready to leap into action at,
at a moment's notice.
But the cortex basically keeps them
inhibited and it seems to do that.
So imagine that you have a vision of
your desired future.
Okay.
And then a vision of the transformation
stages that you're going to undertake to
move from where you are to that desired
future.
Okay.
So then what you're doing is you're
comparing your interpretation of the
present to your interpretation of the
desired future.
And then as long as those two things
match,
which the hippocampus is the hippocampus
is the thing that's determining that,
it's the thing that's computing the
match between your fantasy of what you
want to happen with your fantasy about
what is happening.
As long as that matches,
then the hypothalamus,
the hippocampus basically and,
and we don't know exactly how this
works,
although it seems to work to some degree
through modulation of the reticular
activating system,
the match.
If the hippocampus matches what you want
with what's happening,
then all these other little sub systems
are basically shut off and if they,
if the hippocampus detects a mismatch,
which is when novelty occurs,
right,
rights like something went wrong,
then you get disinhibition of the
reticular activating system.
It's like you wake up and then
everything's primed for action and you
know that solves the problem of what you
should do when you don't know what to
do.
And that answer is you should get ready
to do everything.
You should be on alert and ready to
implement whatever actions,
whatever.
It's not even whatever actions,
it's more like you get,
you should be ready to implement
whatever subpersonalities the situation
seems to call for as soon as you're able
to identify what they are.
But otherwise it's sort of like an army
that's all of a sudden gone on alert.
You don't know who's going to be called
on,
but everybody should be ready.
That's a high stress situation.
Okay,
so,
so part of the hypothalamus is,
let's say for the sake of argument,
it's popping up all these little
subpersonalities that have to do with
basic basic instincts.
The words are all wrong because they're
not like an instinct sounds like a drive
and people aren't driven.
We're not that simple.
We're much more flexible than that.
Even rats aren't driven.
There is a very,
um,
seminal experiment that was done at the
height of behaviorism.
So,
you know,
the idea with the behavior is perfectly
smart idea was that the way a rat
learned was it would start with a
reflex.
It sort of in the Piagetian sense.
And then you could teach it a new
routine,
which was an aggregation of little tiny
reflexes.
You could teach it a new routine by
rewarding it.
So let's say here's what you do with the
rat.
So you want to teach the route to climb
the ladder and go across it a little
ladder.
And so the rats sniffing around in the,
in the,
in that little rat cage,
and then it gets close to the ladder.
And so you give it a food palate and
then it hangs around close to the
ladder.
And just cause you've reinforced,
like you really reinforced the
manifestation of those micro behaviors
that are associated with the ladder.
And then maybe at some point the rod
puts one little paw up on the first
rung,
you give it a food pellet and then
pretty soon the rats going like this
fairly frequently.
And then the next thing that happens is
it puts two paws up there.
And you know,
if your patient using reward,
you can get that rap too.
You can get that damn rap to do damn
near anything.
Skinner taught pigeons to navigate
guided missiles by maps in the Second
World War by packing,
which is,
they never did use them.
But really it's pretty impressive.
You know,
you think pigeons are stupid.
They're not stupid.
They can read maps,
which is pretty damn amazing.
So,
so the idea was that what the animal is
doing is chaining together deterministic
reflexes,
right?
But the thing about a deterministic
reflex is that it's not flexible,
right?
If it's a deterministic reflex,
it really is a drive action,
a initiates action be that initiates
action,
see,
and it's a fixed action pattern.
And some animals do seem to learn that
way.
So there's these little animals,
I think their moles that do this or
shrews shrews.
Let's say you teach a shrew to gill from
point a to b by a very
inefficient maze,
like route.
But the shrew could just walk straight
there.
But once he learns to do this,
but he can't figure out that he's going
from here to here.
Whereas if you train a right to do this,
the rat will figure out,
you know,
to hell with all this circuitous ness,
it's just going to go straight from
point a to point b.
And that was one of the first that that
finding was part of what indicated to
early neuro,
neuro psychological researchers that
animals produced a map of the
environment.
And you know,
in some sense partly what we're talking
about when we're talking about these
structures,
you know the A to b structure is a map.
That's another way you can look at it.
So anyways,
so you've got this rat and its behaviors
are all chained together,
right?
So I already told you,
you know,
I spoiled the story in some sense
because I told you that the rat could
learn to take a shortcut.
But one of the earlier demonstrations of
the independence of rat learning from
the reflective conditioning was that,
so let's say you've trained to rap to
run down a maze.
Okay.
So hypothetically it's using its front
legs and his back legs and it's learning
to chain all that together.
Front leg,
back,
leg movement,
turned left,
front,
leg back,
leg movement turned right,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
While so then,
well,
what if you put the little rap,
you tie up his back legs and you put
them in a little rap like wheel barrel.
So he's got wheels instead of legs.
It's like the route zooms through the
maze swell so much for the reflex
theory,
right?
Because obviously you didn't train the
rat to use a cart with its rear end
stuck in,
hadn't figured that out all by itself.
So,
so,
so anyways,
there's,
there is a system in you that allows you
to chain reflexes together.
It's a very primordial learning system
and the behavior got that right.
It's fast,
very,
very fast because it requires do neuro
connections.
So there's some advantages to simple
learning,
but once,
once you get up into the higher,
even the moderately higher cortical and
subcortical functions,
you're past the point of a mirror
reflects chaining.
Okay?
So let's say for the sake of simplicity,
the hypothalamus says you need waters.
So your current state is you're thirsty
and your desired state.
As you get to go to the tap,
you know,
you can feel your mouth dry and so
forth.
And then some fantasies about drinking,
some water start to come into your mind
and then all of a sudden you're kind of
possessed by that.
And so it's starting to interfere with
your,
with your conscious goal directed
behavior at that point.
And finally it's insistent enough like
something knocking on the doors.
So you think,
man,
I'm,
I'm thirsty.
And,
and you know,
maybe you even think I'll work better if
I have something to drink.
And so you go off to the fountain and
then what your campus is doing is you've
got this little idea,
which is your desired future about how
this trip is supposed to go.
And then you're,
you're watching to see how the trip is
actually going.
But that's an interpretation to,
and then if there's a match between the
two,
the hippocampus just leaves you the hell
alone.
You don't get anxious,
you don't get,
you don't get knocked off the track.
You go there,
you have the water that satiates that
system,
that's a form of rewards,
satiation,
it's called consumer Tory reward.
And then that system disappears.
It goes back to the big dungeons from
which it emerged.
And then in all likelihood,
another one pops up.
Now it's an over simplification of human
behavior to assume that you just go from
one hypothalamic Lee mediated state to
another.
Although I would say that's what two
year olds do.
And in some sense that's what animals
do.
And you know the two year olds doing it
because that little creature hasn't gone
any more organized than hypothalamic,
you know,
so it's,
and you can see this if you watch two
year olds,
it's like they're laughing and then
they're crying and then they're hungry
and then they're hot and then they need
to go to the bathroom and then they want
to play.
It's like it's just one pure motivated
emotional state after another.
It's quite fun to watch.
And they're also relatively hyper
exploratory is as long as and playful,
you know?
But they're cycling through those things
all,
all the time.
So,
so,
so you,
you can't say that that's really what an
adult human gods.
And the reason for that is that
the problem with the,
with the pure,
with the reason that you need a cortex
and the other subcortical structures
that aren't hypothalamic is because the
world is too complex for those
primordial systems to solve the problems
they're supposed to solve.
A in every possible situation,
be across multiple timeframes and see in
an environment that's consists of the
interactions between other very complex
beings.
So you know,
it's almost,
it's almost like an arms race of
complexity in some sense that's driven,
are driven our evolution.
The smarter you get in some sense,
the more variable you get.
And that's a problem because as I got
smarter say over the course of
evolution,
all you people got smarter too.
And so we're all competing and
cooperating with each other.
But the whole damn system is getting
more and more and more and more complex.
So you have to grow a brain in order to
manage that and at least,
or you keep it simple.
Well we didn't keep it simple.
So we decided to grow a brain instead of
you,
I don't know if you know this,
but um,
you ever,
you've looked at a chimpanzee and feel
like they don't look a lot like human
beings,
you know,
I mean there's obviously some things in
common,
you know,
their hands are quite human and their
ears are quite human,
but you know,
their forehead comes down to about here
and uh,
they,
they're kind of shaped like this,
you know,
they're a big round,
they've got a huge round body and
whereas a human being,
it's sort of like,
you know,
a stick with two sticks coming out of it
and two more sticks were really,
really thin.
Hardly any gut.
And whereas the chimpanzees like it's
intestinal structures are way,
way,
way longer than ours.
And so it has to pack that into this
huge gut to the damn.
Chimpanzees sits around eight hours a
day chewing.
And the reason for that is it eats
leaves.
It's like you go out in the forest,
need leaves and see how damn many leaves
you have to eat before you feel full.
It's like all the chimp does is sit
there and chew leaves and then it has
this huge guts so that it can extract
some nourishment out of it.
We figured out how to solve that problem
once we discovered fire and hunting
because within we could cook pays and
then we that enabled us at least in
principle to trade gut for brain,
which I think was a pretty pretty useful
trained all things considered,
although it's still might get us in
trouble.
So no,
cause the brain's a very energy hungry
organ and,
but we very,
very efficient food and it turns out
that cooked food is much more nutritious
from a caloric perspective than,
than raw food.
And so you can,
you can afford to sit around and develop
a brain if you've got high quality food.
Otherwise out there in the,
in the jungle chewing on leaves like an
idiot for like,
they're just about as bad as Pandis.
You know what?
You know why those things are damn near
extinct.
They used to be carnivores.
All they eat is bamboo shoots now that's
it.
Nothing else.
Bamboo shoots and they have no
nutrition.
So they have to like eat bamboo shoots
all day and then now and then the bamboo
crop fails and there aren't any shoots.
It's like,
well,
so much for the parent as it's like if
an animal ever deserved to go extinct,
it was definitely the panda
hunt.
Something yet lazy bastards.
Anyways.
All right,
so now this,
I discovered this about the hypothalamus
when I was reading Larry Swanson is just
bloody well blew me away because,
well,
you'll see why at least in part.
So half of the Hypothalamus,
roughly speaking,
is sort,
sorta devoted to popping up these basic
primal subpersonalities,
the sorts of things that you share with
animals.
But then you might say,
ah,
what happens when one of those doesn't
work?
And the answer is,
well,
you get an anxiety response.
Now the anxiety response is not mediated
by the hypothalamus and neither is pain.
So look,
if you're an idiot,
you're body tells you,
hurts you or tells you or scares you
basically.
But what's interesting about that is
that the pain systems and the anxiety
systems are not in the hypothalamus.
They're separate systems.
Now the pain system is old,
old,
old.
It may be,
it's as old as the hypothalamus.
It's way down there in your brain.
But the anxiety system is a lot newer
and you know,
that kind of makes sense because you can
imagine primordial organisms really
didn't stop until they ran into
something that was hurting them.
They couldn't think,
oh no,
I might run into something that will
hurt me.
Well you can't think that until roughly
you have an egg.
Della,
let's say,
cause the Amygdala seems to be at least
it's responsible for lots of things and
all these areas are interconnected.
But one of the things that seems to be
responsible for,
at least in part is anxiety.
And so when your hippocampus detects a
mismatch between what you want to have
happen and what is happening it,
this inhibits the reticular activating
system.
And one of the things it activates is
the anxiety system.
The anxiety system says,
stop you in it.
You don't know where you are or what
you're doing.
And so you should quit before you get
into trouble.
And we don't like that feeling very
much.
That freezes us.
But it's better than pain.
So you,
you feel anxiety so you don't have to
feel pain.
Now pain seems to occur when you
encounter a stimulus,
let's say a situation where the sensory,
the stimulus magnitude is sufficient to
damage those parts of you that are
encountering it.
So too bright,
a light to auto flame,
to cold,
a piece of metal to hot food,
whatever.
You know if it,
if it's of sufficient magnitude to
damage you,
you get a pain response out of that and
the pain response is supposed to teach
the part of you that moves forward not
to do that again.
The anxiety system responds to cues of
pain.
Now the pain system is pretty
complicated as well because frustration
is a pain like stimulus.
Disappointment is a pain like stimulus,
grief and loneliness are paying like
stimuli.
Depression is probably a pain condition.
So even though the pain system is quite
primordial,
it's grown up like a complex tree and it
subsumes many different functions.
So,
but,
but it's,
it's still a very ancient system.
Whereas the [inaudible] system,
which is newer,
you've developed over time to tell you
what might hurt you so that you can
avoid contacting it.
And so you've got your hypothalamus and
it's telling you,
you know,
it's laying out these little
subpersonalities that are helping you
deal with the fundamental necessities of
the world.
The pain system is there to tell you
when you have encountered a situation
that is harmful,
the anxiety system is there to tell you
when you might be going to encounter
something harmful.
And that's the thing that's activated
when there's a mismatch,
right?
Because the mismatch says you don't know
where you're going,
where are you are,
and so you might get hurt.
Now the other thing that happens,
roughly speaking,
is that when the hippocampus disinhibit
the reticular activating system that
turns the other half of the hypothalamus
on,
and this is quite cool because the other
half of the hypothalamus is the place
where the
ventral tegmental area is located in the
ventral tegmental area is the part of
the brain from which the dopaminergic
tracts emerge.
And those are the tracks that you use a
to explore and be to respond to cues of
conservatory reward.
So what that means in non technical
languages,
that when you encounter mismatch,
you get anxious,
which is what you should do.
You should stop,
something's wrong.
And then as long as nothing else happens
that's painful or threatening,
then that system starts to climatize.
Partly because you're looking around and
thinking,
right?
It's,
people often talk about this as
habituation.
That's a stupid idea.
It's habituation.
If you're a sea slug,
it's not habituation if you're a person,
except that very,
very primordial reflects like levels of
the nervous system at the higher order
levels that we're talking about.
It's learning.
And so if you stop and you're anxious,
what happens?
Well,
generally speaking,
you start thinking what the hell might
be going on?
And you're running through all of these
different theories and,
and part of the way that works is that
it's partly a consequence of state
dependent learning.
So if you,
if you're anxious,
you're going to be primed to remember
situations that you are anxious in
before and why should you do that?
And the reason for that is
anxious things that make you anxious is
at category.
It's actually a category.
Now we tend to think of categories as
something that exists in the objective
world,
but that is not how your brain
categorizes things.
You have to learn that really painfully
to make objective categorizations for as
far as your natural nervous system is
concerned.
All things that go bump in the night are
the same thing.
And what is that?
While it's some bloody horrible,
ah,
predatory Crocodilian dragon like
monster that hides under your bed and
comes out in bites you when you were
three.
I just ran a little paper today about
this kind of cat that lived back when we
were still figuring out how to use
spears and this was a particularly nasty
kind of cap and it preyed on us roughly
speaking.
And we didn't get eaten by too many cats
because cats really can't bite through
the skull so they could go for your
neck.
But that was,
you know,
they didn't necessarily kill you,
but this cat had a mouth that fit right
around your skull and it had two teeth
that went in here and two teeth that
went in here and it was a silent killer.
And there is evidence that even children
are capable of recognizing the motion
pattern of a predatory cat.
And one of the hypothesis is that we
still have,
you know,
all of our primate ancestors that didn't
get eaten by that particular cap,
we're pretty damn good at detecting
cats,
at least have that type.
And we seem to have,
what would you say,
conserve that ability at least to some
degree.
So you think about a category,
it's like,
you know,
you might think,
well there's fish and there's birds and
there's,
and there's mammals and there's this
reptiles and you know,
those are,
those are linnaean classifications.
They're based in some sense on,
on evolutionary divergence and,
and where they're not on morphology on
the way the animals put together.
Who Cares about that?
Things that eat you.
That's a category and you need,
you need that category.
And then the other category is also
things that mighty you.
So things that eat you,
you know,
those are things that can hurt you and
things that you,
that mighty you are things you haven't
classified yet but might be dangerous.
And so that's your natural,
your brain's natural category one of
them.
And then you might think,
well,
if that's the natural category C,
that's the sort of thing that,
um,
the guy who wrote the visual,
an ecological approach to visual
perception,
he talked about as an affordance,
that was the word I couldn't remember
last week.
So an affordance is something whose
meaning you instantly perceived.
And so you might say,
well,
no,
you see a cat and then you infer that it
might eat you.
It's like,
no,
no.
You see something that might eat you and
then you might be able to figure out
that it's a calf,
but it's,
that might eat you,
that you see first,
not the damn cat.
And so this is,
this is a fascinating phenomenon.
It it,
it suggests like the hi to Gary Ins have
proposed that what you perceive first in
the world is meanings and out of the
meanings you extract objects.
It's not the other way around.
And so if you look at the way your brain
is organized,
that's how it works folks.
Because the more primordial your brain
system is,
which means the more ancient it is,
the mortar tied it is into your
survival.
The more it's perception is action
predicated,
you know?
So for example,
if you hear a loud noise behind you,
when you startle,
that's your response while you're going
into a crouch.
That would make it difficult for a tiger
to bite the front of your neck.
And you do that.
Like that's big man,
that's before your it's way before
you're thinking.
It's before you're perceiving.
You know,
consciously you're not getting images or
sounds at that point,
it's so quick.
And that's a,
that's a category.
Things that make you go like this and
that's a good category.
Now,
the reason I'm making such a case about
that categories,
that's one of the mythological
categories is things that go bump in the
night.
And then one of the things that
primordial people were trying to figure
out is,
you know,
you could take up any old animal is
thinking as figuring out how to escape
from a Predator that isn't what human
beings wanting to figure out.
Not once we were able to abstract.
What we wanted to do instead was to
figure out how to escape from the class
of all things that could eat you.
Not just any particular old thing,
but all of them at once.
That's the advantage to categorization.
Can we arrange things so that nothing
can eat us?
Well?
How do you go about doing that?
Well,
believe me,
we've been working on that problem for a
very,
very long time and one of the answers we
came up with,
we'll get into this later,
is the idea of sacrifice and sacrifice
is a very,
very ancient idea.
But I'll,
I'll just give you a bit of a preview.
It took me like 20 years to figure this
out.
Human beings discovered sacrifice a long
time ago and they acted it out before
they understood it.
Okay?
Because we act out all sorts of things
before we understand it.
And idea is sort of,
well,
you can make a bargain with God.
You might say,
well what's God?
Well we'll,
we'll approach that problem later.
It's a very complicated problem.
But one thing you could think of God as
is God is the anthropomorphic
representation of the entire social
structure across time.
So you might say,
well God will reward you if you behave
property.
But what does that mean?
Well,
imagine that you could conceive of
everyone who wasn't you as one met a
person.
Okay,
imagine that that met a person is gone
and you can make a deal with that thing.
You can say,
well,
if you behave,
if I behave properly,
that mess have being will respond,
pause property to me in the future.
It's like it's true,
right?
You know that if you make a promise to
someone and you keep it,
then something good is likely to happen
to you in the future.
So that was one way that God,
that's God the father derivation.
It's,
it's far more complicated than that.
But that's,
that's not a bad point.
And we kind of figured out that we could
bargain with it across time and that
that would work.
So I read a really interesting paper by
someone who's actually a former student
of mine is iem sheriff.
And he analyzed the relationship between
criminal behavior and belief in hell
across a whole set of countries.
I don't know when it was an exhaustive,
you know,
if it was an exhaustive analysis,
correlational analysis,
it's way more peaceful in countries
where people believe in hell.
So you know and you think,
well should you believe in hell?
It's like okay,
well yes and no.
You know,
atheist arguments aside,
we're not even going to bother with them
cause they're kind of moronic so well
the idea here is that there are certain
views,
there are certain action patterns that
if you undertake you will be viciously
punished in the future.
It's like,
yeah,
that's going to happen.
You try lying to everyone that you meet
and you just see how well you do over a
20 year period,
man,
you're going to be in such trouble by
the end of that 20 year period.
That hell will be the only accurate way
to describe where you're situated.
So it's no joke,
these are real things.
And people came up with these ideas for
a reason.
Now Hell isn't only where other people
put you if you're bad,
it's a lot more profound,
the concept of that.
But that's not a bad start.
So anyways,
the sacrificial notion was something
like we could not do what we want to do
right now and do something else and
that'll make things better in the
future.
I mean,
think about that people,
that's the most brilliant idea human
beings ever came up with.
There's this old story,
which is probably not true about how to
catch a monkey.
So you get this jar,
it's got a pretty thin neck,
just big enough for a monkey to put his
hand in.
And then you fill in with things monkeys
like deed,
say like let's say hard candy just for
the sake of argument.
So you put that out there and then the
monkey goes in and sticks his hand in
and grabs a bunch of candidate,
can't get his damn handout because it's
only big enough for an input is,
and then so then you can just go pick up
the monkey.
It's like,
well,
what's the problem with the monkey?
It can't sacrifice.
It won't sacrifice its grip on the damn
candy for it's future existence.
It's like that's what your parents had
been teaching you ever since you were
little kids,
let go of the candy so that you can live
and you know,
that's delay of gratification,
right?
That's conscientiousness,
man.
That's the discovery of time and its
relationship to the social environment.
It's so brilliant,
you know?
And part of what people were trying to
figure out when they were developing
these rituals of sacrifices.
Okay.
So you think about society as a metta
person.
It's usually represented as male by the
way,
but not always.
It depends on the circumstances.
So what is this a person want?
What you've got to kind of figure that
out.
Partly what it wants is don't eat all
the damn grain today.
Save some for next year.
Right plan.
Act as if the future exists as part of
the social contract.
God,
that's such a discovery now.
You know it's,
it's not,
it's only people who figured that out.
I mean squirrels have kind of it in some
sense because they store up knots,
but you know,
I mean the squirrels and squirrels are
smart.
They just kind of got the inkling of it,
you know?
And I think what squirrels do is they
eat all the nuts they can possibly eat
right now and then they store the rest
of them.
It wouldn't go hungry to store nuts for
the future,
but human beings will do that.
Don't eat the seed grain.
Right?
Cause then you're going to die next
year.
Okay.
So all right,
so back to the hypothalamus.
Now you're doing something you want to
do and you're tracking how that's going.
Both of those are hypotheses by the way.
And all of a sudden something happens
that you don't want to have happen.
Like you live in Flint,
Michigan for example.
And so you decided to go have some water
and it turns out it's not water at all.
It's land.
I don't know if you guys know about
that,
but it's quite,
it's quite,
you know,
it's just the sort of thing that makes
your jaw drops.
So you know,
the state is in big trouble,
Michigan and so they appointed an
auditor to control finances.
I believe at the state level might have
only been at a city level but doesn't
matter,
let's say the state level.
So the auditor was looking for ways to
save money and one way they decided to
save money was to re to hook up Flint
Michigan's water supply to a river
instead of to the Great Lake,
which is what it's right beside.
It turns out since flint was at an
industrial center for forever,
that the water's just plum full of lead.
So now they have like 50,000 lead
poisoned people living in Flint,
Michigan.
That is not a good thing.
Led lowers your Iq rapidly and it makes
you violent.
So it's for the $10,000 they saved,
they probably cost themselves half a
million dollars per person.
It wasn't actually that there was lead
in the water,
it's that the water was more acidic.
Oh,
it took the lead out of the pipes.
Yeah.
Okay,
okay.
Right,
right.
Good point.
Well,
I'm not here to complain about Michigan
politicians,
but the point is is that just because
you think you're out for a drink of
water,
that does not necessarily mean that's
what's going on and that's why I said
you're comparing your vision of the
future to what you think is going on
right now.
Now,
if you read the the neuropsychologists
like vinegar Nova in Socal,
often Jeffrey Gray,
they're basically behaviorists.
And so what they tell you is this,
and this is different.
What they tell you is that you have this
little expectancy map.
It's like the map the rat has of his
surroundings.
It's a spacial temporal map.
And so when you're doing something,
you expect a certain outcome.
Okay?
And then what?
You compare that to his reality as it
unfolds.
Okay?
So you could say you've got this map and
then stimuli appeared to you,
and those are objectively real.
It's like,
no,
that's wrong.
It's wrong.
You're,
it's interpretation everywhere.
You think you know what's going on right
now and you think you know what you
want.
And the reason I'm making such a big
deal out of this is because look,
if you're a rat and you're going about
your business and something you don't
want happens,
according to the gray behaviors model,
you have to revamp your map,
your expectancy map.
But according to the bottle that I'm
proposing,
it's way worse than that because you
don't know where the damn mirror is.
It might be in your map of what you
want,
not what you expect.
That's a different thing.
But it also might be in the map you have
that,
that's of the present.
So it's not just the map that you have,
it's a prediction of your actions that's
at fault.
It could easily be the way that you're
construing the World Right now.
And it could be error at any level of
behavior.
And so what it means is that when an
anomaly you'll occurs,
it spreads doubt through the entire
hierarchy that we were describing,
including the future and the present and
even the past.
And you,
you know this,
you know this perfectly well,
you can see it when you encounter a
complex and normally so a complex
anomaly would be you have a longterm
relationship and you get betrayed.
Okay?
And so betrayed means you've trusted
someone and they've enticed you to do so
and then they exploit that trust and her
view for Dante that betrayers were in
the lowest circle of hell.
So it's a particularly nasty thing to do
to people because in some,
you know,
if you think about trust as the
precondition for interpersonal
relationships,
which it is,
then if someone acts towards you in a
way that violates your trust in trust,
they've done you the worst disservice
that someone could possibly be done.
Okay?
So you get betrayed.
All right,
so bang,
that's an anomaly.
What does it imply?
Well,
that's the wrong question.
The right question is what doesn't it
imply?
It implies that you just don't have the
foggiest notion of what you're doing or
what human beings are like.
You know?
And that's,
especially if it's a particularly
vicious betrayal,
maybe you know,
you've been suckered by a psychopath.
It's like,
okay,
update your model and account for that.
Good luck.
Especially if you're naive,
because the probability that you'll be
able to reach down into the depths far
enough to come up with a coherent
explanation for why someone would do
that is very,
very low.
You know?
And what I've discovered in my clinical
practice is that if you get betrayed
badly enough,
the only language that you can use to
describe it is fundamentally religious.
At some points of of betrayal,
it's good versus evil.
It's malevolence and them.
It's the malevolence that really
traumatizes people.
It's the,
it's the fact that that person was out
to hurt you.
It's like,
oh,
well,
what's a human being like when they're
capable of that?
It's like,
it's an age old question.
Now I'll tell you something is weird and
interesting.
So there's this old idea in genesis,
the first idea,
one of the first ideas in genesis is you
know that God made people a paradise to
live in.
Okay?
So let's just be wild about this for a
moment and assume that you're a little
model when it's going well is a little
paradise,
right?
It's like the world's turning out the
way you want it to,
but there's a snake in there somewhere
and that means,
well,
why is there a snake?
Well,
because there's a bunch of things you're
not paying attention to while you're
going about your business,
right?
In fact,
there's almost an infinite number of
things that you're not paying attention
to,
and the problem is one of those infinite
number of things that you're not paying
attention to.
Consumers shift on you all of a sudden,
and so there's always a snake in the
garden and then you have to figure out
what to do with it.
The thing is,
if you interact with the snake,
you get more conscious,
but the problem with that is you lose
your little paradise.
Okay,
well it's worse than that because that
story is really old,
but we have no idea how old it is.
It's disseminated all over the world or
it emerged independently in different
places.
We don't really know.
But in any case,
it doesn't matter.
It's a fundamental enough story.
Tree plus snake plus people that no
matter where you go with,
some people have tree snake stories.
So,
and I think that's because we lived in
trees for like 30 million years and we
got eaten by an awful lot of snakes.
And so,
you know,
it's a story that really appeals to us.
And every bloody science fiction movie
you go to,
most of the time,
if the aliens are bad,
they're always reptilian.
You know,
it's like you don't get Furry Little
Koala aliens that are chasing you
around.
It's like,
it's like the ones that alien,
you know,
they're a reptile inside a reptile,
they're nasty beasts and they come out
inside of you even,
you know,
which is another symbolic idea.
So,
okay,
so you've got,
you've always got the damn snake and
it's popping out to all the time and
there's nothing you can do about it
except get ready to deal with snakes.
No getting rid of them.
So that's the first lesson.
You're not getting rid of the damn
snakes.
You better learn to deal with them.
Then the next question is,
what is the worst possible snake?
Now,
one of the things that happened in
Christianity,
and this was influenced in part by
Zoroastrianism,
was the idea of almost an independent
eval arose.
You know,
in,
in fact there was a branch of
Christianity called Mannequin that
construed the world as a battle between
good and evil,
where good and evil had equal reality
and they were in this eternal battle.
Now that got wiped out by,
uh,
by the standard Christian theory,
that evil is actually just the absence
of good,
which anyways,
you can have a big debate about that and
people have for thousands of years.
But as Christianity developed,
there's this weird mythology that grew
up around the weird myth in genesis and
the weird mythology was that the snake
in the garden of Eden was also sake.
And then he's the king of all evil.
It's like,
okay,
what does that mean?
It's pretty straight forward.
What's the worst predator?
Well,
that's easy.
The worst predators,
a human being.
And so the worst of all possible snakes
is the most malevolent possible being.
And that's exactly right.
And that's why that association was
made.
It's so,
and it's so interesting because it took
people like thousands of years to make
that association,
you know?
And it wasn't really put together well
until Milton formalized it in paradise
lost.
And so it's like we kind of observe this
in action.
You know,
that there were bad people.
Okay,
so bad is a category.
But what is bad entail while mythologies
of eval center in on the central
features of what constitutes bad,
you know,
and carnivorous might be one of the
things.
Money malevolent out to hurt,
right?
Be trail lying.
All the cardinal you could take of the
cardinal.
Great.
Since that's the worst snake,
while it's a psychologize aviation of
the idea of the Predator.
And you know,
it's even more sophisticated than that
because one branch of that theory is
that the worst Predator is the evil
force outside of you.
But the next branch of that is that the
worst proud Predator is the evil force
within you.
Yeah,
well that's when it gets really
psychologized we take,
well that's,
you know,
is that superstition?
It's like,
hey,
that's not superstition,
boys and girls.
It's a lot more intelligent than that.
It's the most sophisticated theory of
the way things work that we have and
it's correct.
Now what that means from a metaphysical
perspective.
We're not going to talk about that
because we can't,
but we can certainly talk about what it
means in practical Darwinian terms.
You better know what's after you.
And the worst thing that can possibly be
after you is a fully motivated and
completely malevolent human being.
It's like,
you know,
skull crushing cats be damned.
You know,
all they want to do is eat you.
They're not going to torture you.
Whereas if you fall into the hands of
the wrong human being,
man,
you could be an excruciating pain for
the next 20 years.
So people are very imaginative when they
figure out how to hurt someone and they
can keep it up for a long time and
they're fully motivated to do so under
some conditions.
And so you really got to watch out for
that.
So,
all right,
so back to the hypothalamus.
So when you have a mismatch between what
you desire and what you're after,
then the hippocampus says,
oh,
we don't know where we are.
That's what it says.
You no longer know where you are.
Okay,
what should you do when you don't know
where you are?
You should stop moving and then you
should,
well then what?
They should prepare to do a lot of
things.
Okay.
Then one,
then you should explore.
Well,
that's where the other half of the
hypothalamus comes in.
That dopaminergic circuit that mediates
positive emotion,
right?
Almost all the positive emotion that you
experience in your life,
the kind you like,
which is hope and curiosity and
expectation and,
and surprise.
And,
and,
and that's all mediated by the
dopaminergic systems.
It's a major league contributor to your,
to the totality of your being,
especially in a positive direction
that's rooted in the hypothalamus.
And so what that means is that it's
quite cool.
You got your fundamental motivations,
you know,
your basic blood biological motivations.
Bang,
they fail.
What happens?
Anxiety.
That's a newer system and exploration.
That's an older system.
That damn exploratory system has been
there forever.
Now if you look at classic hero
mythology,
which we're going to do in great detail,
what you see is that the typical myth of
it of humanity is we live in a place,
we'll say we have to live in a place and
the place is doing quite nicely.
Thank you very much.
It's like the hobbits and,
and uh,
Frodo,
right?
The first one,
the Lord for the,
uh,
what was it called?
The hobbit.
Okay,
so you've got a little shy or they're
right.
It's all peaceful.
It's full of these little people who are
a little on the arrogant side.
They're kind of dopey.
They have no idea what the hell is going
on in the outside world.
But they think that's okay.
They think,
you know,
just,
peculiar people are concerned about that
sort of thing and they got their little
happy paradise going.
They live a long time,
they eat a lot,
you know,
they party a lot.
Um,
unbeknownst to them,
which is very interesting feature of the
story.
The only reason they have any peace at
all,
it's because they are descendants of old
kings continually patrolling the
borders.
Right.
Those are the striders Eric Gordon,
he's the member of the race of old kings
who patrols the borders.
Well those are,
those are ancestral figures.
It's like you can all sit here,
your little happy paradise,
but the only reason you can do it is
because the sons of great kings have put
borders around your kingdom and you can
think it's funny cause in the Harbutt
that hobbits basically despise strider.
You're like,
they're very,
very suspicious of him.
He's kind of dirty and dusty and he
looks like he's been banged around all
over the world.
He sort of like a trout.
It's like they don't know.
He's the son of a great king.
Good thing for them that he is.
However,
okay.
So then you've got the little Shyer and
what happens?
Evil things are stirring.
And what is it?
Well,
fundamentally it's a great dragon.
Well that's a snake,
except it's like medicine snake.
You know,
it's,
it's snake with fire.
And you can be sure that fire was not
only one of our greatest allies,
but one of our greatest enemies,
especially when we lived on the belt in
Africa.
Cause that thing would burn now in that,
you know,
and so get the hell away from that and
on.
Well,
so anyways,
so one hobbit who's woken up by a
wizard,
right?
The wizard is a symbol of the self from
the union perspective.
So there's one hobbit who's a little bit
more creative and exploratory than the
rest.
And everybody has little respect for
him,
but they think he's pretty damn
peculiar.
He decides that he's going to under the
tutelage of the wizard,
he's going to go check out this dragon.
So he leaves the borders and he goes out
into that unknown.
And then the rest of it is an adventure.
And one of the things that's very
interesting,
again,
from a union perspective is that what is
the hobbit have to become in order to
conquer the Dragon?
A thief.
Now that's pretty weird.
A,
because you'd think,
hey man,
this guy's out to be a hero,
so you should be a hero.
It's like,
no,
he turns into a thief.
Why?
Well,
it's because if you're going to conquer
a dragon,
you better be a hell of a lot tougher
than you are naive.
And so partly what happens is that for
the hobbit to muster up the forces that
are necessary for him to confront
something,
that that is that fundamental,
he has to transcend his coward.
What would you call it?
The,
the cowardice that he describes as
morality.
Okay,
so Nisha,
for example,
each is often viewed as a critic,
critic,
critic of morality.
It's like that's not true.
What?
Because nature identifies morality with
cowardice,
but that's not what he does.
What to says is this.
If you're too afraid to do something so
you won't do it,
then you'll say that the reason that you
don't do it is because your moral.
That's not the reason.
The reason is it's you're too damn
afraid to do it.
You might want to,
but you're too afraid.
That doesn't make you moral.
So what happens to the Harbutt,
for example,
is once he gets outside the kingdom,
he asked to develop a whole array of
potentials that he never developed
before because they were either not
necessary in his civilized place or
because they were forbidden as immoral
by the cultural situation that he grew
up in.
Say,
well,
think you have to be touched by the,
you have to be touched by the snake in
order to defeat the snake.
Where else have you seen that motif?
It's Harry Potter,
right?
I mean,
Harry Potter's a strange character
because he's not obedient.
Not at all.
In fact,
he's quite disobedient,
but he breaks the rules in the service
of higher morality and the higher
morality is that he faces down the
dragon that paralyzes you and he frees
the virgin.
That's what happens with Ginny Virginia
Virgin.
It's the retelling of Saint George and
the Dragon.
And interestingly enough,
the reason that Harry Potter revivified
is because the double doors phoenix
comes by and cries in his wounds while
the Phoenix is something that dies in
his reborn.
And so the men have myth underlying the
second volume of the Harry Potter series
is that the part of you that sustains
you through an encounter with the
dragon,
that paralyzes is the part of you that
can die and be reborn.
And what that means in a sense is if
you're wrong about something and you
fall into a pit,
then you should let go of what you're
wrong about so that something new can
arise.
And so it's better to be,
it's better to be the thing that
transforms in response to catastrophe,
that it is the thing that's static.
Yeah.
And that's another big discovery of
people.
We are,
we're like,
we're agents of transformation,
which is of course why kids are so
bloody obsessed with magicians and
wizards who are agents of
transformation.
You know?
And that's all embedded in the
mythology.
It's all acted out.
Nobody understands this sort of thing to
speak of.
Certainly the kids don't.
It just hits them,
you know,
cause they can recognize the pattern.
They know that there's something magic
about them.
Even though they're living in a cupboard
in a London suburb where everything is
boring and flat and under control.
That's not the real world.
And it's true.
It's not.
Is that why we have more patients or
people including criminals who say who
admit their crime
selves?
Oh well not only no.
Know more patients we off often have
admiration for them.
Oh yeah.
I mean like how many movies feature up
attractive bad guy while or for that
matter it attractive bad woman.
You know,
it's like,
it's because it's because of the
Nietzschean observation.
The people who are good aren't good.
They're just cowers where's the guy
who's bad?
Well at least he's not a coward.
Well then you might say,
well,
you know,
yeah,
he could stop being empowered and also
become a good guy.
But I mean that's often,
often,
but not always the actual plot of the
movie.
Cause that's the redemption of the bad
guy.
You know?
It's also what women fantasize about in
relationship to the beauty and beast
mythology.
They don't want the coward.
He's the guy that wants to be the
friend.
It's complete bullshit.
The bad guys in advance over that,
but not a big enough advance because
he's a bad guy.
The best thing you want is a civilized,
bad guy.
It's like that's what you want.
Well,
no wonder because it's only a civilized,
bad guy that's going to be capable of
dealing with the dragons.
It's right Lloyd Axworthy.
When he was the minister of Foreign
Affairs for Canada,
we know all the massacres were going on
in Yugoslavia.
It was front page news at one point.
It was during the ethnic cleansings.
He said,
I don't have the imagination for that
kind of evil.
It's like,
oh,
well that's really impressive,
Mr. Minister of foreign affairs,
did you ever read about the Holocaust?
It's like,
it's time to wake up a little bit.
These things happen,
but he said it has a moral claim.
I just couldn't imagine that sort of
thing happening.
It's like,
well,
it's,
you're a little on the naive side,
aren't you?
And parading that around his morality is
not a reasonable thing to do.
When you also happened to be minister of
foreign affairs,
it's like you should be looking out for
the snakes all at the time cause they're
definitely out there and Milosevic was
definitely one of them.
And so if a naive person meets someone
like that,
the naive person loses and that's not
good because there were lots of people
like that and be better if they didn't
win.
So okay.
So the hypothalamic,
the fact that the exploratory circuitry
is actually embedded right into the
hypothalamus way down there with like
lust and thirst and hunger.
It's so great because it shows you how
the mythology works.
It basically says,
okay,
here's a bunch of things you're doing
now and then something will go wrong.
Okay,
you need a system to deal with things
when they go wrong.
What's the system?
While it might kill you,
bang better,
have some pain and anxiety to protect
you.
Well you better figure out what it is.
Okay.
Better have an exploratory system so
that you can go out there and gather
some more information.
While that's,
that's the human story.
Gather information in the face of
danger.
That's the human story.
That's what we do.
So,
and that's the hero myth.
And the hero myth is a redemptive,
and that's because it is redemptive.
That is what works.
Or at least that's what we've staked our
being on.
I mean,
who knows?
Maybe all of this exploration.
We'll just get us in trouble.
I mean,
that's another part of Genesis,
right?
Poke around and see what happens.
Well,
you know,
you're doing that all the time.
You're in your little paradise battling
away all happily,
and then you just can't stop yourself
from pulling on a thread somewhere.
And then you find out,
oh my God,
you know,
maybe that's when you get suspicious
about your partner cheating on using
maybe this person cheating on me and you
can't leave it alone.
You can't leave it alone.
You got to go look at the snake.
It's like bang.
It turns out it's there down.
You go into the underworld,
right?
And you might think,
well,
maybe ignorance.
You know,
maybe the bliss of ignorance would have
been better.
Well,
it's not like psychologists don't tell
you that.
All those positive illusion people,
that's their whole shtick is right.
It's better to be little bit dumb about
how things work cause otherwise there's
no way you can be happy.
It's like that's an idiotic theory on
two accounts.
A happy isn't the point and be dumb is
not the goal.
So you know,
it's,
it's so,
it's so ignorant that it's actually
corrupt,
which is really saying something because
you have to be pretty damn making rent
before you get to corrupt.
So it's a hell of a thing to teach
people.
You know,
you have to delude yourself in a minor
way,
otherwise you can't stand being alive.
Oh my God,
that's awful.
That's really awful.
It's like here's a different story.
Maybe your Dick Tough enough to open
your eyes.
I'd be a much better story.
And it's possible to,
cause people are really,
really,
really tough.
It's just they live in these little
protected places,
you know,
and they never get out there and hammer
themselves out against the world.
So they never discovered that they're
tough.
But you know,
when you might think,
well that's your opinion.
It's like,
no,
it's not my damn opinion.
We know that if you take someone who's
naive and and,
and paralyzed by anxiety and you put
them in psychotherapy and you expose
them to the things that they're afraid
of or disgusted by end avoiding that it
isn't that they get less afraid,
they get more confident.
And that's what generalizes,
you know?
So you know,
if you bring somebody who's got a mouse
phobia,
need them house for the year,
then they're not ever afraid of a bunch
of other things.
Why does that happen?
Well,
they weren't afraid of the damn mouth.
You're afraid of their own inadequacy
and then you teach them that they don't
have to be afraid and they think,
hey,
I don't have to be afraid.
And then they're not afraid of a whole
bunch of things.
And so you get generalization from
behavioral exposure.
And so it isn't,
there's no question about whether or not
exposure to the things that you avoid is
curative.
It's the fundamental axiom of
psychotherapy.
You know that.
And figuring out what you're going to do
with your future.
But even in psychoanalysis,
it's face what threatens you,
right?
It's just that the psychoanalyst tend to
go after past traumas,
but doesn't matter as far as your brain
is concerned.
A dangerous thing in the past is exactly
the same thing as a dangerous thing in
the president.
And it seems to be partly because the
Amygdala doesn't have any sense of the
time.
And you know,
it's interesting because one of the
things young observed was that there's
no time in the collective unconscious.
It's like everything is in eternal now.
So let's say you got traumatized when
you were a kid.
Your age you're in and make the growth.
Maybe you got bit by a spider or some
damn thing.
It's like you're afraid of that spider
then and now.
And in the future it's the same.
It's outside of time.
Hippocampus,
it's the thing that's dealing with time.
So you know,
if you really learn a lesson,
it's supposed to be timeless.
While you know you can still help people
overcome their phobias,
but he can't get their damn Amygdala to
shrink again.
So you can just get it back under
control.
Okay.
So that's pretty cool.
And then we could say,
let's go up a level or two.
Well,
let's look at the Amygdala for a minute.
So
things about the Amygdala have probably
changed since I updated my knowledge.
But it doesn't really matter because the
fundamental systems I'm telling you
about exist.
And they keep moving around in the brain
because we don't know exactly how they
work.
But at a system level of description,
you know,
and with the,
with the,
at a system level of description and
using slightly vague neuro psychology,
we can localize these sorts of things in
the brain.
Okay.
So the Amygdala gets inputs from
everywhere.
And basically what it's looking for is
things that might threaten you.
And I would say the,
you could say in a sense that they'll
make the law has a inbuilt sense of the
monstrous.
And let me show you,
this is a good time to show you,
uh,
a little,
a little comic.
This is a great comic.
Someone stoned came up with this comic
and they really did cause it's a,
it's a,
uh,
head comic,
underground cartoon comic.
But I really liked this comic because it
just shows you what's going on
perfectly.
Okay.
So there's these hippies,
they're,
they're all friends of this guy named
fat Freddy and,
and you know,
they're,
they're basically useless hippies and
they don't pay rent and they only do
smoke pot in there,
you know?
And so anyways,
at one point they make a bunch of money
on some cocaine deal and they buy this
whole mouth in the country and they
think they're going to go out there and
live in paradise.
And so they bring their catalog,
which is fat Freddy's cow who has his
own adventures with cockroaches and so
on.
Anyways,
if you've ever had a cat,
one thing you knew about cats is they
don't like to move.
It makes it very upset and nervous.
And if you put them in a new house,
they are not happy about it.
And the reason for that is you've blown
their map,
right?
It's like the cat will slink around in a
new territory and map every single place
in every hiding place,
you know,
obsessively till it knows what the
hell's going on and then it'll find me.
Relax.
So a cat in a new place is not a common
cat.
A cat in a new place is a nervous cat.
Okay.
Which is also indication that you don't
have to learn to be afraid.
What you have to learn is how to be
calm.
And that reverses the way that
psychologists generally talk about
anxiety because they're all hobbits and
they think that life is safe.
And so they think that because life is
safe,
you have to learn to be afraid.
It's like that's dopey.
The natural condition is terror and
curiosity.
And if you're really lucky now and then
you're somewhere safe enough so that you
don't have to be afraid.
And that's tenuous and delicate.
And so what you have to learn is how not
to be afraid,
not how to be afraid.
So anyways,
they got the cat.
And so he's in his box and they take
them out of the box and the cat thinks,
so this is the country.
And then the cat goes real low and start
sniffing.
And that is what animals do when they
first start exploring both of those
things,
they crouched down and that makes them
less visible to predators.
And they sniff.
And the reason they sniff is because
like most animals are all no's.
You can tell that with dogs for example,
their whole brains are built around
their sense of smell unlike us,
which most of our brain is built around
vision.
But anyway,
so the cat's slinking around there and
then it smells something that it doesn't
know and it thinks God only knows what
this thing that I don't know is.
And so it re it would freeze first and
then it would beat a hasty retreat.
Okay.
So now it's underneath the porch.
One hip,
he says,
where'd the cap disappeared now the
other one says under the house,
and then the cats down there shaking,
which is what cats do after the freaked
out like that.
And it's got this little fantasy going.
You'd hide too if you'd smelled what I
did.
And then it imagines up this monster and
a monster technically is the
amalgamation of unrelated parts.
So what's the monster?
Well,
let's go duck feed and it's called like
bare arms and,
and it's got a skunk tail and it's got
kind of a wolf head and it's got antlers
and you think,
well that thing doesn't exist.
It's like,
that's wrong.
That thing exists.
In fact,
it's a really accurate representation of
what's out in the forest.
Now any one animal wouldn't look like
that,
but the set of all possible animals
looks exactly like that.
And then you might think,
well,
what do you want first when you're
something you want quick and dirty
representation of what to be afraid of?
Or do you want to hang around trying to
figure out whether that thing has hooves
and teeth?
It's like,
no,
you want it quick and dirty
representation of just what might be
lurking out there because that's
intelligent hypothesizing,
right?
It's the kind of hypothesize and it
would be evolutionary driven.
You ever see?
Uh,
the far side cartoon,
uh,
Monster Snorkel.
I loved that cartoon.
So there's this little kid in his bad,
it's dark and he's under the covers.
He's one of those ugly little kids that
Gary Larson always drew.
And he's got this snorkel that you use
for,
you know,
scuba diving and what do you call it?
Snorkeling,
scuba diving and all that sticking out
from under the covers is the snorkel so
that he can breathe.
And then of course in his imagination
there's some like reptilian dinosaur,
like things sitting beside his bed.
And it's like,
well,
why?
Because that's what he's hypothesizing.
Why?
Because that's what's in the dark.
And you think,
well,
you can tell your kid,
there's no monsters in the dark.
Yeah,
right.
And then you say,
never talked to a stranger.
It's like,
get your story straight.
People really,
you know,
it's so dopey.
He's like,
yeah,
there's monsters in the dark.
So what are you telling your kids?
No,
there's no such thing as monsters.
First of all,
they're driven half crazy because they
think,
well,
what am I afraid of?
Then?
You know,
and second you tell them over time that
there are monsters in the dark.
In fact,
you're probably more paranoid about the
damn things then your kid is,
you know,
so what do you tell them?
There are monsters in the dark,
but you can probably handle up,
especially with our health.
Okay.
So now I'll tell you a story.
So my nephew,
he was six,
he had night terrors in night terrors or
this strange phenomena where all of a
sudden you wake up screaming is quite
unpleasant.
And then you might say,
well why was this happening in the
answer as well?
We really don't know.
But there was some instability in his
household at that point.
A,
he was just going off to kindergarten.
So that's a big transition,
right?
It's out of paradise.
I would into the world and be,
his parents were in the throes of
approaching divorce.
So there was that sort of undercurrent
in the house.
Right.
And you know what that's like.
You walk into a house like that,
it's like you know something's up.
It's like the error is frozen and it's
probably something that you can smell.
I think,
but whatever,
it doesn't matter,
but you can certainly tell.
And so anyways,
he's,
he's waking up at night screaming away.
And so during the day,
he's a very verbal kid.
During the days running around,
I guess he was about four,
not six.
It's got this little night hat that he
wears.
It's a plastic night hat.
So he zooms around without all the time
and he's got this plastic sword and he's
doing around with that too.
And so you think,
well,
what's,
what's he up to?
Well,
he's playing night.
Just kind of weird day because you
think,
why would being a night be attractive to
a kid?
You know,
we weren't nights for that long,
but whatever,
it doesn't really matter.
He's running around playing night and he
goes to sleep and he puts his night hat
and his sword right beside his bed.
So fine.
I watched that.
I'm watching what's going on with him.
I'm figuring out what's going on in the
house.
And you know,
his mom is worried because he's having
night terrors.
It's like,
yeah,
it's horrible.
Wakes up screaming.
So,
okay,
nighttime comes,
he wakes up screaming.
We're all sitting at the breakfast table
the next day.
And I said,
did you dream about anything?
Anyway,
yeah.
And then got right into this dream.
And he said,
okay,
well this is what happened.
I was out in a field and all of these
little dwarfs were around me.
They only came up to my knees,
but they had big beaks.
They didn't have any arms.
They have big beaks on them and they
were covered with hair and Greece.
So they were all greased down and there
was a cross shaped at the top of their
head.
Wherever I went,
these beat dwarfs would jump at me with
their feet and bite me.
So it's like a horrible image,
right?
He said they're everywhere,
so everyone stops eating breakfast and
we're like watching this thinking,
wow,
that's no wonder you're screaming man.
So,
and then he said,
yeah.
And it was worse than that because like
there was smoke and at the back of the
little doors there was this dragon and
the dragon was breathing out,
smoke and fire and the smoke and fire
would turn into the dwarfs.
It's like,
oh my God,
what do you do about that?
Wiping out some dwarfs.
It's like,
who cares?
The Dragon.
We'll just breathe up some more.
It's like that's life man.
I've got this.
Excellent.
I've got this excellent picture.
It's,
let me show it to you cause it's,
it's worth finding even though it's
going to interrupt my story a little
bit.
Yeah.
Well I'm not going to find it because
it'll take too long,
but I'll tell you what it is anyway.
So it's a Greek amphora.
All right.
You Know How am fora there?
Those,
there's like a boss sort of and they
just keep winding them and uh,
it's dreary.
It's painted on like a,
like a cartoon.
It's sort of black and white and it's
got this hero who I believe is Hercules.
And anyways,
her,
these is facing this snake and it's a
really cool snake.
So first of all,
its tail is curled in a perfect circle.
And that's if you look at dragons and
snakes and mythology,
there are often their tails often curled
in a circle and it means something like
it means something like infinity.
But anyways,
and then there's all these snakes.
It's a high drug,
so it's a snake with like eight can say.
And so then there's Hercules with his
sword.
It's like,
well what's the problem with the hydro
cut off one hand?
What happens eight more heads?
It's like,
hmm,
quit cutting off heads.
Yeah,
it's a good piece of foreign policy
advice for the Middle East.
No.
So the hydrus keep growing.
Okay.
So you know,
cutting off heads isn't going to be of
any utility.
And so here's what the story is saying.
It's like no matter how many problems
you solve,
there's going to be a bunch more
problems.
And it's even worse than that.
If you have a problem and you solve it,
that's going to lead to more problems.
So even the solution is a problem.
Right?
And that's the law of unexpected
consequences,
right?
That's why automobiles have destroyed
the atmosphere.
Everybody thought in automobile is for
getting from point a to point b.
It turns out it's not.
It's for transforming the world into the
world's holes,
into jungles.
We didn't know that.
So that's an unexpected consequence.
So anyways,
the kid is faced with this horrible
conundrum,
like,
what am I going to do?
Go out these doors and they're biting me
and then there's this stupid dragon.
So I said,
what could you do about that?
Now that's called a loaded question and
it will be inadmissible in a court of
law in a sense,
because it,
what is it?
It's a question,
but no one isn't right.
I'm telling him something,
you could do something about that.
Well,
that's a hell of a theory.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
I should just lay down and let the door
of seat me,
you know?
No,
no,
you could do something about it.
I said,
what could you do?
And then he said,
I put my hat on,
I get my sword.
Then I'd go get my dad and we'd go up to
the Dragon.
I jumped on his head and then I poke
both his eyes out with my sword and then
I go right down the stomach to the place
where the fire comes out.
And I cut a piece off of that and I'd
use it as a shield.
And I thought,
right,
art and Kid,
you got it,
you can fight.
It was so cool because he had the whole
thing,
hey,
and that's why he's running around
playing night.
He'd almost go on it and all I had to do
was drop.
There's this fifth chemical phenomena
called a supersaturated solution.
It's kind of cool.
So if you take,
you know,
water can only dissolve so much sugar
until the sugar starts to crystallize
out,
right?
But if you're careful,
you heat up the water,
you can dissolve a bunch of sugar in it.
And then if you really slow,
slowly cool down the water and you don't
tap it and there's no impurities,
you can get this sugar,
you can get this solution super
saturated,
which means weirdly enough,
it holds more sugar than it can.
It's like it forgets to crystallize it
or something.
Or maybe you know,
it needs a little impurity or a shock or
something to get it going.
But it's like,
it forgets to crystallize.
So then if you take a little crystal of
sugar and you drop it in,
it's like he goes and instantly,
it's all crystal.
So,
so that's what happened to this kid.
It's like he was there,
he was ready,
he had the answer.
And all I had to do is say you could do
something about this and Poof,
instant hero myth.
And the cool thing is no more night
terrors.
So well,
so you get the picture.
It's very,
very cool.
All right,
so back to our discussion now.
so you've got the brain here.
And so this is uh,
the brain has conceptualized by
Alexander Luria who was the Russia's
most famous neuropsychologist and who
got the big picture,
right,
man.
So basically he said there's a bunch of
different ways that you can divide up
the brain.
You know,
it kind of,
it depends on what you want,
you know,
which is an interesting way of thinking
about it because you might say,
well,
how should you divide up the world?
And that's her is,
well,
it depends on what you want,
right?
It depends to some degree on the
features of the world,
but it depends even more on what you
want.
So one of the things Luria said,
it's okay if you go from the back to the
front of the brain,
the front of the gray part here,
what you see is roughly speaking,
the back half of the brain does sensory
processing,
especially visual processing.
And the front half of the brain does
motor processing.
Okay.
And so if you look at the back of the
brain,
the sensory unit there,
you see that there's an auditory area
and a visual area.
And what's cool is those overlap to some
degree.
So there's some hypothesis that the
places where the sensory systems
overlap,
it are the parts that are responsible
for your experience of a unified
perceptual field.
So here's an example of managing the
visual cortex in the auditory cortex.
Overlap in one place.
Okay?
So it sort of be maybe hear about there,
let's say on the left side.
Yeah,
there,
that's the part used for silent reading.
Isn't that cool?
It means you're using your eyes,
his ears and the way you do that is
used.
The overlap between the visual and the
auditory cortex.
It's so cool.
You can use your eyes his ears.
So,
you know,
so the senses aren't as separate as
people think.
And you know,
when I,
I used to wear glasses and I couldn't
hear what people were saying when I
wasn't wearing them.
And the reason for that is I couldn't,
I wasn't watching their lips say.
And so a lot of what I was hearing in
language processing was the expression
on their face and the movement of their
lips.
So take off my glasses,
I'm deaf.
So anyways,
so that's the sensory unit.
Half the brain,
most of it's visual cortex because we're
insanely visual creatures and the front
half is the motor unit.
Okay,
why?
Well,
because we proceed and act.
So it's the part of the brain that's
responsible for Zika.
You around you,
you've got voluntary action,
right?
You,
you inhabit a nervous system that
enables you to navigate your way
throughout the world.
We're navigators fundamentally,
we really are navigators and you don't
ask can navigate by the stars.
Think about that.
How the hell can enact navigate by the
stars.
They figured that out by figure,
you know,
watching ants is figuring out how to get
back.
And then up the sky,
and then the ants were wandering around
not knowing where they were going.
It's like,
yeah,
there's lots of things we don't
understand.
I can tell you that.
So anyways,
the motor unit,
you've got the motor strip.
Now if you touch that with an electro
during brain surgery,
then people will either move or have the
impulse to move and you can map out how
the body is represented in the brain by
touching that strip with an electrode.
And that was done by wilder Pinfield at
the Montreal neurological institute.
It was a major move forward in the
understanding of the brain.
And he did that on epileptics before
surgery because he didn't want to take
out parts of the brain that you know
were necessary.
So he's trying to figure out what they
were doing.
So that's the part that enables you to
act voluntarily.
And in front of that,
there's the premotor strip.
And then in front of that,
there's the prefrontal cortex.
Now what's cool is that the premotor
strip and the prefrontal cortex grew out
of the motor strip over the course of
evolution.
So then you might say,
well,
why do we think,
and the answer isn't so that we can come
up with accurate objective
representations of the world.
The answer is so that we can plan what
to do and what you see fundamentally is
that as you move forward in the brain,
you go from action to planning action.
And so by the time you get to the
prefrontal Cortex,
let's say the Dorsolateral prefrontal
Cortex,
which is the part of the brain that you
use for abstract thinking,
what you're basically doing is conjuring
up avatars of yourself in an imaginary
world running the mess simulations in
your imagination and the collective
imagination.
That's what stories are,
and then running the simulation to the
end to see if you live or die and if you
die,
then you don't implement the simulation.
And if you live in thrive,
then you do implement the simulation.
And so
was it Karl Popper,
philosopher of science said,
the reason we think is so that we can
let our thoughts die instead of us.
Right.
That's smart.
Well,
that also ties into the death and
rebirth idea,
right?
It's like are you going to die?
Are you to let your,
you know your avatars die?
And one way of thinking about that is
that your current self is just an
Avatar.
Now if you understand that,
that means you also understand the
relationship between the union self and
the ego.
The Ego is an Avatar.
The self is the thing.
Now,
I don't know if you know this,
but the word Avatar,
it's actually a theological term.
It's from,
it's from Sanskrit and an Avatar is the
form that God takes on earth.
It's pretty cool that that turned into
the word for the thing that you use at a
video game,
right?
That's your little,
you know,
disposable self.
You throw it out there in a world and it
can live or die and you're back there
like God,
just be an eternal all along the way.
So that's a very,
very thing.
But anyways,
even before we had video games,
we were doing that,
right?
Cause we had fiction,
we had stories,
we had imagination and it's,
it's decoupled from our motor systems.
And so we can implement these,
you know,
hypothetical instances of ourselves
before we implement them.
And you know,
that's Kinda how we fight hydrus.
It's like,
okay,
you got eight snakes,
what do you do about that?
You'll have eight potential selves.
So you multiply potential cells just as
fast as the world can multiply snakes,
you know,
and that's what evolution does,
right?
So you know,
let's say you've got a mongoose,
mongoose,
mongooses,
they like to eat snakes.
They're really good at it.
They can eat cobras,
go mongooses.
So you think,
well a mongoose gets killed by a Cobra.
It's like,
well it's not a very good mongoose,
but that doesn't matter because the
mongooses are generating all sorts of
Mongoose and one of them is going to be
able to kill the snake.
Not all that.
That's all that really matters.
So there's a very funny mouse that lives
in the desert in Arizona.
I'd like this most a lot.
And it jumps and it,
it's so cool.
This mouse,
it feeds on Scorpions.
It's like,
how the hell did it learn to do that?
Anyways?
It has to teach its young to eat
scorpions and it's quite immune from
Scorpion Vanneman Venom,
which is quite helpful.
But still,
you know it goes out in this,
it's like you going out to wrestler Nile
Crocodile,
it's like a scarf.
He and he's a big thing compared to a
mouse.
The mouse will hop on the Scorpion and
they have this terrible fight and
finding the most tears it apart and then
it brings it back and feeds it's little
mice,
babies pops and you know what it does.
Then it goes outside and howls at the
moon like a wolf just sort of,
it sounds like a mouse.
So it's really squeaking out.
But if you slow it down,
you know,
which is what you have to do.
For example,
if you want to hear mouse vocalizations
cause they're often super,
super what,
what uh,
above,
above your threshold for hearing pay
excepted that to here or rats laugh when
you tickle though.
He had to slow down their vocalizations
because they,
they laugh at ultrasonic frequency.
So he had to slow down your,
their vocalizations to hear them laugh
when you take a look.
But anyways,
these damn nice go out in the desert at
night after eating a scorpion and they
howl at the moon,
which is like
go mice.
So,
so anyways,
anyways,
back to the brain here.
So there's all these terrible monsters
being generated and you generate avatars
of yourself to cope with.
I'm in generally used to have to like
evolve to do that,
but human beings being the smart
creatures we are generated up and the
environment in the imagination and then
populated it with imaginary
representations of ourselves and then
try those out and then we implement the
ones that we think are great.
And then you might think,
well we've been doing that for a very,
very,
very long time.
And then you might think,
well maybe we figured out exactly what
thing we should implement.
And then we might say,
well that's the savior figures in
mythology.
That's what they are.
So what else would they be?
You know,
people would be trying to figure out
what the hell we are for forever.
And the fundamental question isn't what
is reality maideb not the fundamental
question.
The fundamental question is how do you
act in the world?
And that's a whole different way of
thinking about the world.
But I think given that I'm a Darwinian,
I think it's the fundamental question.
And you know what?
Obviously,
given what I've described to you so far,
you can't fall in love too much with
your current self.
Because what if it's wrong?
Well,
you should let that sucker die.
And so then you might think,
well,
what part of you is it that doesn't die
when your Avatar's die?
Well,
that's what you'd called the self.
So let's say you got undergo a
personality transformation here.
There's the old view,
you're all naive a and something comes
along and just wallops you bang into the
underworld,
you fall apart.
Hey,
and then bang,
there's a new you and maybe a little,
you know,
battle weary but wiser,
fine.
But then you know that one gets walked,
walked out and bang into down the road
and up you come again.
It's like fine.
What's constant across all those
transformations?
That's the core element of,
of the,
of the person.
That's what you called the self
brilliant.
It's brilliant.
So smart.
Okay.
15 minutes and then we'll,
we'll go on.